this is it this is the beans on the
toast I've had beans and I've had toast
I've never had beans on toast I've never
heard of beans on toast I've usually
heard that beans are best served with
barbeque I'm a big fan of all the
components so I expect it's gonna be
delicious
the beans just look like look like
SpaghettiOs gone wrong you know it
smells almost like nothing it looks like
a vegetarian sloppy joe there's no so
nasty you know this isn't bad
the bread is the exact same consistency
as the duties but yeah it tastes like
the fourth of July which for a British
food is pretty hot I don't know what I
think it just tastes like totally edible
flavorless beans on toast I've eaten a
lot of other weird things and this is
definitely not the weirdest thing honey
I don't know why people are creepy right
I mean that's what I see I see a lot of
lonely British men going home to their
flats and preparing this for dinner
wishing they had a wife
I think beans on toast will catch on in
America because Americans love beans
everyone loves games and I don't get it
I mean hey we all have our things that
we eat that are different and you know
what if it works for you then why the
hell not put beans on toast all right
okay if I were gonna make beans on toast
it would be whole-grain bread
guacamole black beans chili and that
that's basically already up hope